STEVE MALKOS: Welcome.
I'm truly excited
to be here today
to talk to you guys about
location and sensors.
Get the clicker.
My name's Steve Malkos.
I'm the Technical Program
Manager for the Android
Location and Context Team.
I was amazed earlier
today to hear Sundar talk
so much on sensors and context.
Being part of the
location and context team,
we touch every part
of Google, and I'm
truly excited about that.
So without further ado--
OK, let's get into it.
Today, we carry the
world in our pocket.
We carry more computing
power and faster data
speeds than we did
just nearly half
a decade ago from
our desktop PCs.
One item that has remained the
same throughout our computing
history has been building
these innovative software
applications.
And you guys are continuously
shaping this world.
But we need to do more.
We can do more.
We could build deeper
and richer experiences.
In this talk,
we'll focus on what
it takes to build an
awareness application.
We'll go through
sensors and location,
focusing on bringing richer
experiences by using them.
Then, we'll take a deep dive
into the Android sensor hub
and go through the
cool new things
that we're building for it.
Awesome.
OK, so what does
it take to build
these highly contextual apps?
So what does it take to build
these high-quality apps?
Today-- sorry, the
notes are not right.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Let me
take care of that for you.
STEVE MALKOS: Our phones are
very personal and interactive.
They have transformed the
way we compose our day.
We use them to get traffic
info, health and safety,
and notifications and much more.
So it's understandable
that your biggest concerns
are on how to make your apps
more contextually aware.
So let's focus on
what it takes to build
these high-quality apps.
When creating these
awareness applications,
there are typically three main
layers that we need to look at.
That's sensors, algorithms,
and user experiences.
Think of an awareness
application like a human sense.
For example, your inner ear
acts as the accelerometer
and gyroscope of the device.
Your eyes act as
the camera sensor.
That raw data from
your ears to your eyes
gets sent up to your brain and
processed like the algorithms
on the device.
That's then classified into
the context and outputs
as the user experience,
like I'm running,
or I'm running with a buddy.
MEMS Sensors allows us to take
a deeper programming perspective
on comprehending the
environment around us.
So when building these
contextual applications,
we're going to focus on
these four main pillars.
That's coverage, accuracy,
latency, and power.
We'll refer to these pillars
throughout the entire talk.
These are the building blocks
for creating higher quality
applications.
Let's walk through
examples of each of these.
The first pillar is coverage.
For location it must work all
the time-- indoors, outdoors,
and in every country.
At Google, we're continuing
to improve our coverage
maps with our
crowdsourced models
and Google databases to
make location better.
For activity recognition,
it has to support
a wide array of different
types of activities,
like I'm running, or I'm
walking, or I'm in a vehicle.
And nearby notifications needs
to work across a wide array
of different types of devices.
Finally, sensors have to
work seamlessly and uniformly
across the entire ecosystem.
The second pillar, accuracy.
From the macro view, GPS
must be very accurate.
Users don't want position jumps.
They want the positions to be
under 5 meters all the time.
Indoor and outdoor
transitions also
have to be as
smooth as possible.
From the macro view that we
saw on the previous column
to the micro view on
position accuracies,
it must work perfectly
for our virtual world.
Examples a better
virtual reality
could come from sensors.
Sensors that output less
drift at lower noise.
A user also wants very
accurate activity detection.
For example, it's not OK
to classify biking activity
if you're shaking your
leg in a moving car.
The third column that I'd
like to discuss is latency.
From the macro view,
users don't want
to wait for their positions.
Location should show
up instantaneously.
And activity detection needs
to happen near real time,
so the user's entire
activity can be
tracked with almost no latency.
From the macro to the
micro on latencies,
our sensors cannot lag.
When we have sensor and
display lags like this,
your virtual world can go
from making a beautiful scene
to making you
nauseated very quickly.
We want the experience
to be crystal clear.
We take great care in ensuring
that our sensor latency
requirements are met.
This ensures that when you
write your applications,
you can be certain
that they'll perform
to your user's expectations.
Our final column, power.
That's battery life, one of
the most important columns
when building your applications.
We all know that if your
application sucks up
the user's battery
life, they'll quickly
uninstall it from their device.
We need to make it
where you guys don't
have to worry about power.
We can do this by
avoiding too many knobs.
Simplicity is key.
Power has even two sub-pillars.
That's latency and accuracy.
It means we could run more
often improving on latencies.
It also means we could get
access to more signals,
thus improving on accuracy.
So in the theme of building
better user experiences
by bringing higher quality
applications focused
on coverage, accuracy,
latency, and power, let's
hear from Ashutosh
on Android sensors.
[APPLAUSE]
ASHUTOSH: Hi.
Thanks, Steve, for
setting out the lay
of the land for the rest
of the presentation.
I'm Ashutosh, and over
the next few minutes,
we shall be talking about how we
set about achieving these four
pillars of contextual sensors.
I hope to give you some insight
into the challenges we face
and the power we derived in
working with the ecosystem.
I shall show you some of
the new and shiny things
we have in store for
you for Android N.
And finally, we'll share
some of the lessons
that we have learned
in developing Android
experiences, which will probably
be of value to you as well.
A challenge that we face
is a constant tension
between increasing
coverage but formally
defining new sensors
in Android and ensuring
that we can keep a
consistent user experience
across the ecosystem.
Let me give you an example.
We have received requests
to allow accelerometers
that only support two axes.
These are required
for low-end markets
where the z-axis is not
required if the only thing
that accelerometer does is
detect landscape and portrait
detection.
On the other hand,
we have been asked
to mandate a higher dynamic
range for accelerometers
because it allows some safety
applications to be developed,
which can potentially
save lives.
The problem is that
these two goals
are mutually contradictory.
A sensor that only
supports two axes
will not have a
high-dynamic range.
The economics of the
industry work against it.
The example goes to coverage.
We must ensure that all
Android sensors can eke out
the maximum visibility from the
hardware while also ensuring
that the application developers
seek consistent APIs across all
of Android.
Over the years, we've steadily
added new formal definitions.
While the major physical
sensors, like Excel, Gyro,
and Mag were defined
very early on,
we've continued to define
new capabilities, like sensor
fusion, geomagnetic rotation
vector, and new center
types for completely
new form factors
like Android [INAUDIBLE].
These new capabilities
increase coverage
to develop awareness
applications
because more sensor
types mean that we
can get more data about
the world around us
and derive richer inferences.
We're adding a few things this
year for the Android N release.
Let me walk you
through some of them.
Let's start with
something really exciting.
All orientation
sensors thus far were
centered around orientation.
They provided the
orientation of the device
in terms of roll, pitch,
and yaw with reference
to either true north of gravity
or an arbitrary initial point.
We're adding the three
axes of translation freedom
by introducing the
6DOF sensor type.
Apps will not only
know the orientation,
but the precise displacement
of the device in the world.
This means that motion
control in games
can go just beyond tracking
where the user is looking.
Now they will be able to move
the player in the virtual world
just as the player
moves in the real world.
You can walk and not
just been in place.
Augmented reality experiences
will be even more immersive now
that they can mirror
the user's movements.
Just to set
expectations, this sensor
is not likely to be widely
pervasive across Android.
But we believe that the
introduction of a formal sensor
type is required
to give the system
a push towards augmented
reality applications.
On the wearables
fun factor, we're
extending the
capabilities of what
is available through
the heart rate sensor.
Thus far, you have been able
to get an average snapshot
of the heartbeat
measurement, which is great,
but it leaves a lot of
information on the table.
We will expose a much
more finer-grained event
for every heartbeat, which
should more or less correspond
to the systolic peak
for each heartbeat.
This will enable a whole new
class of fitness and wellness
applications, like
reporting and monitoring
mental stress, physical
stress, overtraining,
exercise recovery, and
sleep analysis, et cetera.
And you guys will be
writing all of them.
One of the most often repeated
requests from our developers
to us was to expose the hardware
capabilities to determine
the motion state of the device.
We are adding these sensors
to the Android sensors
API as one-shot events.
We shall exposed two of them.
One shall fire if the
device centers are
a stationary state
and one that fires
if the device starts moving.
We hope that this will allow
the applications to be more
judicious in the use
of system resources
and developers will use this
ability of motion determination
in low-powered hardware to
get their resource usage.
Finally, this year we realized
that applicant processors
and display controllers
are now smart enough
to enter low-power states.
If only we did not keep pinging
the application processor
with x amount of data to
compute the device orientation.
So we're formalizing
the screen orientation
as a new sensor type that can
be implemented by the OEMs
to get the low-power domains to
compute the device orientation.
However, developers
can and should
continue to use the Android
Activity and Window Manager
APIs.
Android will ensure that
regardless of the underlying
sensor support, your app will
continue to work seamlessly
across all addressable devices,
and if the sensor is supported,
you get all the power benefits.
Finally, we are
adding capabilities
to allow applications
on an Android device
to discover and subscribe
to external sensors
through the sensor's API.
By external sensors
here, I mean any sensor
that is not present
on the device
when the device boots up.
Now, this can be
unnecessary for the device
that physically
attaches to the device
or a truly external device
that connects wirelessly
to your phone.
This is a nod to the central
roles our phones have
in our lives and the realization
that a single device cannot be
all things to all of the
people all of the time.
Device capabilities
can be augmented,
and we want to
provide a standard way
to access such data.
What is coming up is exciting,
and I cannot wait to see what
cool things that developers will
come up with these new sensor
types.
Having decided how we
want increased coverage,
how do we establish
accuracy and consistency?
How do we ensure that when a
new API version is released,
what makes it to
the app developers
is consistent across Android?
This is a complex process
and involves the hard work
of hundreds of talented people
across the Android ecosystem.
Let me walk you through
some of the challenges.
Android is diverse.
Just on the hardware
side, there are
300-plus OEMs, 200-plus
carriers and operators,
hundreds of component vendors,
dozens of CPU SoC vendors
with a range of products.
There are dominant players
that have huge market shares,
and there's a long tail that
caters to very specific niche
cases.
Somehow we have to ensure that
we're listening to everyone
and helping everyone in
the ecosystem succeed.
And then there's the
sheer range of devices
that Android can support.
All of the devices on this
slide are Android devices,
the same specifications
rule them all, more or less.
There are a few
restrictions or mandates
that Android stipulates.
As an example,
it's completely OK
to make an Android device
without a single sensor type,
not even an accelerometer.
That sounds bizarre
if one thinks
of Android purely as
a cell phone platform
but is immediately obvious
once you think of Android TV
products and convince yourself
that determining the device
orientation of a TV would be
an [INAUDIBLE] case at best.
So what does it really
mean to support a sensor?
What sensor should
a device have?
What guarantees, if many, are
made explicit of the developer?
And how?
These are difficult
questions that keep us busy.
And versus agreement
on these goals,
how does this diverse
ecosystem take its cues?
What tools do we use
to make this happen?
In a nutshell, we
drive this process
by creating standards
for Android,
producing exemplary
Android devices at Google,
and working in
tight collaboration
with our partners.
The very first step
is the definition
of Android compatibility.
An Android device is supposed to
meet 100% of the specifications
as defined in the
Android Compatibility
Document, the Android CDD.
It goes into lots of
gory details about what
kind of sensor should
be on a device, how they
should be announced,
and if announced,
what bar they must meet.
We tuned the CDD language
to advise the ecosystem
on what is coming down
the road and match them
into more aspirational
requirements.
The CDD is enforced through
the CTS, a Compatibility Test
Suite.
All Android devices
must pass the CTS.
There are no exceptions or
any waivers for any device.
We keep adding CTS tests to
patch hold in our testing.
Note however, that the CTS is
an enforcement organism only.
It cannot possibly cover
the entire specifications
exhaustively.
The artifact of
record is the CDD.
What do we expect of developers?
Please take a look
at the Android CDD
if you're looking to deploy an
app across a large user base.
It will help such expectations
on what is standardized
and what to expect.
Google devices are
another tool we use.
All Google devices
are great devices.
They also serve to set a bar
for the rest of the OEMs.
Our Nexus device is subject to a
lot of scrutiny outside Google.
The OEM scrutinize
it to make sure
that their devices in that class
are as good as, or even better,
than the Nexus.
They also use that
opportunity to figure out
the holes in our specifications.
If something is ambiguous,
a reasonably good assumption
would be to go along with
what the Nexus is doing.
The implication here is obvious.
Do test your applications
on Google devices.
I think most of you follow
this practice already,
but please, however, go
beyond just the Nexus
that launches this year.
Do test the applications
on previous Nexus devices
and extend your testing
to, say, Android 1 devices.
On the sensor side,
we go even further.
Last year Google wrote the
sensor stack completely
by itself.
And we are releasing the
complete sensor stack
source for the Nexus
devices in open source.
You can get the code for
the sensors of software
at the depository on this slide.
We have two primary
reasons to do this.
The first is to make life
easier for the ecosystem.
They now have access
to the source code
that runs on the Nexus
devices and should
be able to comply with
all the requirements we
are putting forth and
hopefully even do better.
The second is guidance.
We hope that simply by
releasing the source code,
we can wear intents and
expectations very loudly.
In fact, if you look at
the source code released
you will find the beginnings
and the genesis of some
of the future work that we
shall release in Android N.
We have not written a ton
of formal documentation yet,
but we are finding
that our partners are
reading the release
source and coming up
with a very good idea
about what to expect.
Finally, we must continue
to build internal expertise
to keep abreast of the
developments in this space.
We learn constantly
and continue to invest
in internal capabilities
to learn more about sensors
and their algorithms.
Let me show you
how here at Google
we're innovating new
groundbreaking methods to test
our solutions and improve
the quality of our sensor
algorithms.
Can I play the video, please.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In this video, you'll
see Matt programming one
of our robotic arms
to simulate arm
swinging for pedestrian
[INAUDIBLE] solutions.
In this example, you'll
see two things happening.
First, Matt will start by
using a motion capture system.
The motion capture system
is able to record Matt's arm
swings with
centimeter-level precision.
We then translate the exact
motion of that capture system
into a robotic arm.
The robotic arm
then repetitively
tests that specific scenario
on an automated basis
again and again.
That gives us the
ground crews for us
to test our algorithms
and sensor solutions.
Let's watch.
That was cool.
And Matt seemed to be having
way too much fun on there.
The final tool in our
chest is collaboration
with our partners.
We work very closely with our
partners throughout the year
to make sure that they are
aware of what we are doing.
This is a symbiotic
relationship.
The partners want to make sure
that their product roadmaps are
aligned with ours so they're
not caught by surprise by any
of the announcements we make.
We on the other hand
want to make sure
that we're not
shouting into thin air
and have realistic expectations
about what is achievable.
We meet them constantly
throughout the year.
Every year we hold
an Android boot camp
and give them a
glimpse of our plans.
On the sensors
side last year, we
conducted many summits with
sensor vendors, SOC vendors,
and the OEMs.
If we are successful,
nothing that I'm saying today
would be a surprise to
any of our partners.
They should be sitting
back and saying,
we've got this taken care of.
Just a cool thing for you-- why
do you think they listen to us?
Other than our
charming personalities,
the reason they do
is because they want
to reach you, the developers.
Some of the best and the
brightest on this planet
are developing incredibly
exciting technologies,
and they want them
to be exposed to you.
We are merely
facilitating this meeting
of immensely creative and
smart people from both worlds.
The ecosystem is what we
derive our inference from.
The ecosystem is what we serve.
Takeaway-- reach out to us.
Let us know what
you're looking for.
What is missing?
What needs improvement?
What is truly exceptional
and you want more of?
You'll find plenty
of ways to reach us
at the end of the presentation.
The Android sensor's
API has not only
become richer by adding
more sensor types,
it also gives great
control for the developers
to optimize system performance.
In the next few
minutes, I would like
to talk about some
recommendations that
will make your apps scale across
different tiers of devices
and should under the hood
optimize for the hardware
that your app is using.
I will use power as an example.
As to the extent
possible, you want
to spend as little
power for your apps.
Let us look at some ways that
will help you achieve this.
On many devices, there's
a multilayered approach
to processing, at least as
far as sensors are concerned.
At the very source, there are
sensors like the accelerometers
and the gyroscopes.
Sensors today have come
a long way from years ago
and themselves consume
very little power.
They're really power efficient.
Accelerometers and gyros today
take less than a milliwatt
to sample data.
They embed smart algorithms like
gestures and motion detection.
Some even have rudimentary
programming frameworks
for customization.
Then there's the
application processor.
This is your big
honking chip that you're
using when you're running
apps or playing games.
Running the
application processor
takes a substantial
amount of power.
So if every time you try to
process a single measurement,
you wake up the
application processor,
it becomes limiting
very quickly.
All the power savings
from the sensors
are dwarfed if the application
processor wakes up too often.
It consumes a lot of power
and is incredibly powerful
competition but is
also very power-hungry.
It has to stay on
for a few seconds
even if it needs to do a
little bit of processing.
It needs time to
wake up and sleep.
If every time you get
a sensor measurement,
you wake up the
application processor,
it never gets a
chance to go to sleep.
So getting the application
processor to sleep
is a key power-savings
technique.
Modern hardware adds
an additional layer
for sensor processing.
We show that as a sensor
hub in this diagram.
This low-power
compute domain may
be part of the sensor itself,
a special power domain
on the SOC, or a discrete chip.
Its goal, however, is the
same-- to offload competition
from the application
processor and save power.
There are a few hooks
on the sensor's API
that let you achieve this
goal-- for example, batching.
You can use the
sensor's API to specify
the maximum delay your
application can tolerate
to receive sensor data.
This means less frequent updates
to the operating processor.
The events can be grouped
and processed together.
The bigger those toys
buffer than the hubs,
the more power is saved.
Another design pattern
is to specify the goal
that you want to achieve
and then be woken up when
that situation becomes true.
Then the low-power hardware
can monitor for the decision
to become true instead of the
main application processor.
This allows always on
monitoring of events
that would have been prohibitive
by looking at the raw sensor
data all the time.
As an example, if you wanted
to change the app behavior,
when it looks like the user
has moved from one place
to another, you can
use a combination
of geofences and the
significant motion sensor type
to gate your processing.
For the end release, we
have added new sensor types
to detect motion
and stationarity.
By using the right triggers,
you will consume power
only when needed, and not just
a moment of interest for you.
A less obvious design
pattern is to use the highest
level of abstraction possible.
While the APIs may
look like they're all
exposed at one
level-- if you become
a little familiar with
how the system is built,
you will be able to
see where in the system
the APIs are tapping into.
Take, for example, the
sensors, accelerometers, gyros,
and magnetometers.
If you access the
raw data, the system
must ensure of its
end of the contract
and give you accurate,
reliable, and timely data.
It cannot and should
not put in any smarts.
However, if you ask for
the rotation vector,
the same sensors are
used and data is fused.
It may be tempting to roll
your own sensor fusion
algorithm by processing
the raw data directly.
However, you will lose hardware
optimizations on the table.
As an example,
most devices today,
if they're computing the
rotation vector in hardware,
sample the underlying sensors
at an extremely high rate,
sometimes in the
order of kilohertz.
There is no way we can support
that frequency of updates
on the application processor.
And if by rolling your own
sensor fusion algorithms,
you will be leaving power
and performance on the table.
So this is pretty complex.
I hear you.
We have been trying to come
up with a specification
the less the application
developers know
that the sensors on a
device are top notch.
In the [INAUDIBLE] release,
we added exactly such a signal
for the developers.
We call it Hi-Fi sensors.
If the feature is
defined, you will
know that the sensors
are really accurate.
There are stringent requirements
on the resolution range
and performance of all
the expected sensors.
You will know that a large
batch size is supported allowing
you to conserve battery.
You will know that the
time stamps on the sensors
will be very highly accurate.
For many applications that
integrate sensor values
over time-- for example,
Dead Reckoning--
and error in the time
stamps is the same
as an error in the sensor
value itself, and often worse.
Finally, you will know the
sensors are low latency.
Hi-Fi sensors have stringent
latency requirements
to support all possible
real-time interactive use
cases that we have run into.
Checking for the Hi-Fi
sensor support is very easy.
This code snippet
shows you how to do it.
We're simply looking for a
feature string to be declared.
So with a quick query
to the package manager,
you can be assured that your
device has great sensors
and will support all
the fundamentals pillars
of contextual awareness.
Sensor capabilities
are improving,
getting more ubiquitous.
I'm guessing a huge demand for
these additional capabilities.
We are the location
and context team.
We're constantly working
on integrating sensors
into everyday user experiences
to make Android devices useful
and a delight to use.
Location is the other
huge and complex answer
that [INAUDIBLE] is consumed.
I will hand it over
to David to walk you
through that part of the story.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID: Thanks, Ashutosh.
Hi, I'm David, and I work
as a software engineer
on the Android location team.
You've just heard about a lot
of the exciting capabilities
we have with low-level
sensors, and now I'm
going to talk about our
higher-level location APIs
and how they do a lot of the
sensor fusion work for you.
The Fused Location
Provider is our primary API
for producing locations.
It combines many of the sensors
Ashutosh just talked about,
including GPS, Wi-Fi, cell,
accelerometer, magnetometer,
and gyroscope.
It's used by Google Maps to
power the current location
blue dot and by
Google Now to provide
invisible assistance
like reminding you
where you parked your car.
Android apps provide input
hints on accuracy requirements
and frequency, and
the FLP decides
which sensor to turn on in
order to manage both power
and accuracy within the
constraints of user settings.
In the next few
slides, I'll dive
into the details of
some of these sensors
and show how the FLP uses them.
GPS is one of the most mature
location sensors that we use.
And when it works, it
usually works great.
It shines outdoors when you
have a clear view of the sky.
But it has some trouble in
cities with tall buildings.
And when you're indoors, it
often doesn't work at all.
It's relatively power
hungry and eats the battery
pretty quickly when active.
The FLP will use GPS when an app
requests the highest accuracy
location available.
It will also sometimes use
GPS for a balanced power app
request on newer devices
that support GPS batching.
Wi-Fi is another staple
location technology
that has become
more and more useful
as Wi-Fi access points have
proliferated around the world.
Unlike the GPS, it
works well indoors
where people
typically have Wi-Fi.
The accuracy usually
isn't as good as GPS,
but it's good enough to tell
you what part of the building
you're in and often
what floor you're on.
Like GPS, the power
isn't great, but it
can be improved by reducing
the location frequency.
And knowing which cell tower
you're connected to also
gives a very coarse
estimate of location.
It can usually tell you which
city you're in and sometimes
which neighborhood.
Unlike GPS and Wi-Fi, it
works both indoors and out.
And the battery
life is great given
that the cell modem is
continually reconnecting
to cell towers anyway.
So GPS, Wi-Fi, and cell are the
foundation of location sensors
surfaced through the FLP.
But one of the
best parts of using
the FLP in your applications
is that you continually
take advantage of new
Google developments
in both hardware adoption
and algorithm improvements.
Most of these improvements
become active in your apps
without any code changes.
In the next few
slides, I'll highlight
some of the improvements
we've recently made
and show how to take advantage
of them in your apps.
As I mentioned before,
dense urban environments
are very challenging for GPS.
When driving near
tall buildings,
it's common for the
location to drift or jump
to the wrong block.
At Google, we test
GPS on a variety
of phones and environments.
This image shows a
setup for a driving test
that we perform in
San Francisco, which
is one of the harshest GPS
environments on the west coast.
We use a military grade
inertial navigation system
that provides centimeter-level
accuracy in order
to collect ground truth
location for comparison.
We also take video imagery
to compare position jumps
and lags when all devices
are in navigation mode.
This gives us the
automated ability
to count and measure each
device's position jump
or lag and then produce
a report listing
the exact moment when
a device experienced
these lags and jumps.
This is an example test drive
in downtown San Francisco.
You can see a lot of
issues with this track.
Positions clump together,
poor latency, and even
some positions inside buildings.
In order to solve some
of these problems,
we've work with our
GPS chipset partners
to incorporate their sensor
fusion algorithms that
combine accelerometer,
gyroscope, magnetometer,
and barometer with raw GPS
pseudoranges, the chips that
can fall back to
these other sensors
when the GPS signal is weak
providing a much better user
experience.
This image shows the
before-and-after result
of this GPS chipset fusion
working on a Nexus 6P.
You can see the
blue line provides
a much more stable
position resulting
from this fusion as the user
drives in an urban environment.
We've also tackled accuracy
in our Wi-Fi location models.
Over the last year, we've
improved indoor median accuracy
by 40%.
In Google Maps, this
can mean the difference
between knowing you're
in a shopping mall
and knowing how close you are
to the actual store you're
trying to find.
We've added significant use
of the inertial sensors--
accelerometer, gyroscope,
and magnetometer.
These sensors don't tell us
where the user is directly,
but they describe
how the user moves,
so we can use them in
conjunction with GPS and Wi-Fi
to improve location.
One example of how the
FLP uses the accelerometer
is by activating it when
the device is stationary
in order to save power.
Rather than performing costly
Wi-Fi scans over and over
again, we rely on the
low-power accelerometer
to tell us when the device
moves at which point
we resume Wi-Fi scanning.
We also use all three
of these sensors
to improve the accuracy
of Wi-Fi location.
If you open Google Maps
indoors and walk around,
you may notice the blue dot
follow you around the building.
As I mentioned
before, Wi-Fi accuracy
alone is not that great.
But by using sensors,
we can count your steps,
detect when you
turn, and combine
this information
with Wi-Fi to hone in
on a more accurate location.
Now Ashutosh already talked
about sensor batching,
where we can accumulate sensor
data on low-power hardware
and process it later.
Likewise, we've added
support in the FLP
for location batching where it
collects location data at lower
power and processes a batch
of locations after the fact.
If your application doesn't
need immediate location updates,
you can save significant
battery by requesting batching.
This allows the FLP to utilize
sensor batching under the hood
and also to consolidate
network queries.
An example of this
use case might
be a fitness app that
tracks the user's activity.
They usually periodically
want to check their progress
throughout the day but
doesn't necessarily
need constant updates.
Unlike the other FLP
improvements I've mentioned,
location batching
requires code changes
in order to activate the
power savings in your app.
Here's a code example
to activate batching.
You use a location
request object
to provide your apps
constrains to the FLP.
The set interval
method tells the FLP
how frequently to
compute locations.
To activate batching
the magic wait call
is setMaxWaitTime,
which tells the FLP
how frequently to deliver
locations to your app.
So in this particular
example, the FLP
will compute a
location every minute
but will deliver them to the
app every 5 minutes, typically
in batches of 5 locations.
Now, back to the
fitness app example.
Let's say it's batching
the user's locations,
and then the user
opens the app and wants
to see their
progress immediately.
The app can call
flushLocations, which
tells the FLP to interrupt
the batch in progress
and deliver the most up-to-date
locations as soon as possible.
The user will see all
locations collected in the app
and then batching will continue
as previously requested.
So by making a few
code modifications,
the fitness app
can take advantage
of location batching with
significant power savings
while still providing the same
responsive user experience.
Now that we've seen the latest
features of the Fused Location
Provider, I want to briefly
overview another set
of location APIs-- geofencing.
The geofencing APIs
notify your app
when the user enters or exits
predefined areas of interest,
such as their work or home.
It's built on top
of the FLP, so it
inherits all the
new features we just
talked about that improve
accuracy and conserve power.
In addition, geofencing
uses activity recognition
to dynamically manage power
based on the user's speed
and proximity to the
geofences of interest.
This code sample shows
how to incorporate
geofencing into your apps.
You define up to 100
circular regions of interest
and register for notification.
I've highlighted the set
notification responsiveness
call because it's very
important for minimizing
power consumption.
It specifies the
delay you can tolerate
and receiving notification
when the user enters or exits
a geofence.
So your options set
this to be as high
as is reasonable
for your use case.
So I've shown a brief
overview of our location APIs
and how they do the work of
fusing the latest and greatest
sensor technologies for you.
Now I'll hand it
back to Steve, who's
going to talk about our
upcoming hardware features
and how we plan to incorporate
them into our APIs.
Great.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE MALKOS: Awesome.
Thanks, David.
We just heard how we're moving
more and more algorithms down
into our low-power
processing domains,
or how we just want to
offload as much as we can
from the main
application processor.
Next, I'm going to
take a deep dive
and talk to you about
the Android Sensor
Hub and the cool new things
that we're building for it.
OK.
Our mission with the
Android Sensor Hub
is to use all sensors
in all wireless radios
on a mobile device so
we could have a better
understanding of the state
of the user's context
and location.
We want to simplify our
user's interactions.
For example, pick up
to wake the device.
We want to augment human
memory and knowledge,
like we did with Google
Now with Where's My Car.
And we want the users to
have a better understanding
of themselves, like Google Fit.
So what did we launch?
In Marshmallow, we launched
a standalone microcontroller,
which runs always on processing.
We did this on the
Nexus 5X and 6P,
and we open-sourced
it to the ecosystem.
Why did we need this
separate processor?
Today the cost of
computing activities
in an always on fashion
for location and activity
recognition is really cost
prohibitive because of power.
By introducing this tiny
three-by-three-millimeter chip,
we could reduce latencies,
improve accuracies without
hardly affecting the
user's battery life.
I'd like to highlight though
that sensor hubs are not
anything new.
They've been around
for many years.
However at Google, we wanted
to standardize on this output
so that there's more
consistency in the ecosystem.
This gives us better
insurances that when
you write your
applications, they'll
work the same
across all Android.
So what did we do?
How did we do this?
We connected the following
into the Android Sensor Hub--
accelerometer, gyroscope,
magnetometer, barometer,
proximity and
ambient light sensor.
By establishing
these connections,
we were able to
achieve the following.
I'm not going to read
through this whole list,
but I want to highlight
some examples.
It's running everything
in sensors.h.
This includes things like
game-rotation vectors gravity.
We're running significant
motion detector,
which is the primary use
case for Android Does' mode.
All of our activity-recognition
models are in this hub.
And we introduced new
gestures, like Double Twist,
which is a private sensor
that you could register
your application to today.
So what are we saving
in terms of power?
It's quite simple.
When you run activity
recognition on the application
processor, it consumes
quite a bit of power.
When we introduce
sensor batching,
we were able to cut that
number down in half.
Running that same
activity-recognition model
on the Android
Sensor Hub costs us
just a fraction of the power,
and this is just the start.
So here's a sneak peek on what
we're working on this year.
I'm going to highlight
some of the big items.
We're introducing
GPS pseudoranges.
This is groundbreaking as
it's the first time in history
a mobile application will have
direct access to the raw GPS
measurements.
This is beneficial to many,
but especially the phone makers
because they could use these
measurements to help them
in their GPS
performance testing.
And if you ever
had a bright idea
on how to use GPS measurements,
now's your time to shine.
We're also introducing
personalized
activity-recognition
models because we all
know my step length is
different from your step length.
By having a personalized
model, we'll
be able to better our accuracies
for activity recognition.
With the Android
Sensor Hub, we'll
introduce downloadable code.
In Marshmallow when we
launched activity recognition,
we lost the capability of
updating our algorithms
frequently but gained
the power savings
by running those in
the low-power domain.
In Android N,
we'll have the best
of both worlds--
low-power activity
recognition with the
capabilities of continually
updating our algorithms.
We'll also connect GPS,
Wi-Fi, and cell directly
into the Sensor Hub, which I'll
talk about in the next slide.
So by adding these additional
connectivity signals,
we're going to move our entire
location engine into the Hub.
I noted earlier that
power has two sub-pillars.
Those were latency and accuracy.
By moving the location stack
down into the low-power domain,
we'll improve geofencing
because the location
engine's running there.
So latency will become
better because we
could run more
often, and accuracies
will become better because
we will have access
to more signals.
So those are the main
themes for this year.
Let's touch a bit in the future.
In order to truly understand
the state of a user's context
and location, we need to
answer the following three
key questions.
Where's the user?
Examples-- GPS, latitude,
longitude, geofencing,
which is within your circle
or not, and semantic location,
like where am I?
I'm in Starbucks.
For activity, we need to
answer, what is the user doing?
Are they walking,
running, on a bike?
And for nearby, we need to
answer, which devices can I
connect to?
Which Chromecast
devices are nearby?
So in order to achieve or answer
these three key questions,
we need to push down
everything listed here
into the low-power
compute domain.
For a location, we're already
working on the Fused Location
Provider and
geofencing this year.
For activity recognition,
we'll continue
to add new sensors and new
activity-recognition algorithms
down into the low-power domain.
And for nearby, we'll work
on adding nearby connections
and messages into
the low-power domain.
So by answering these
three key questions,
the Android Sensor
Hub will bring
the best of Google's databases,
machine-learning algorithms,
and Google infrastructure
at the lowest power.
This will allow us
to bring you always
on location and
personalized context.
We'll continue to add
more and more signals down
into these low-power domains.
We've already achieved activity
recognition and sensors
in Marshmallow and soon
are about to launch
location and
dynamically downloadable
code in N. The
future will become
more and more contextually aware
and, by adding these signals,
will help make you
deeper, richer experiences
in your applications.
We're truly excited
about these possibilities
and are looking forward to
ushering a new wave of APIs
for your applications.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I have one last
slide if we could go--
we have a new developers site.
This is a nice refresh site.
Go to
developers.google.com/location
awareness.
We've placed all of our APIs in
a fresh new look for you guys
to access our location
and context information.
We also have a quick
survey that we'd
be really interested in getting
your feedback on our sensor
APIs.
So please go to the
second link and fill out
this quick and easy survey.
You could do it at your
leisure or do it right now.
And then lastly,
David, Ashutosh,
and I will hang outside
for a little while
if you guys have any questions.
Or we have office hours
on Thursday and Friday
at these times.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]